شكرا ليال نحييكم مشاهيدون مشاهدينا
ومستمرون معكم في تغطيه اخر التطورات
بخصوص المشهد في السودان فمع تواصل
المعارك تستمر الجهود الدبلوماسيه لاحتواء
الوضع وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه قال ان
الولايات المتحده تبحث مع شركاء في
السعوديه والامارات ومصر من اجل وقف اطلاق
النار بسودانه بينما حذر الامين العام
للامم المتحده من ان العنف في السودان
ينظر بحريق كارثي كما قال قد يبتلع
المنطقه
منذ بدايه القتال في الخامس عشر من ابريل
قتل مئات الاشخاص وجرح الالاف يجب وقف
العنف والذي يهدد بمساه في المنطقه كلها
ادين القصف على مناطق المدنيين وادعو جميع
الاطراف لوقف العمليات في المناطق
المسكونه انا على اتصال مع اطراف الصراع
وادعوهم لخفض التصعيد والعوده لطالت
الحوار
وفي اخر التطورات الميدانيه حتى الان اعلن
الجيش السوداني استقرار الموقف العمليتين
الجيش اشار في بيانه الى توسيع نطاق تامين
منطقه الخرطوم لتجنب الحاق اضرار بالمناطق
السكنيه فيما جدد دعوته لعناصر الدعم
السريع بالاستسلام بينوا الجيش تهمه قوات
الدعم السريع باستخدام المدنيين دروعا
بشريه واكد البيان ان الاتصالات ما زالت
مستمره مع الدول الاجنبيه الراغبه في
اجلاء الدبلوماسيين
في المقابل اتهمت قوه دعم السريع الجيش
بتنفيذ غاره جويه على احياء سكنيه متفرقه
من العاصمه الخرطومه اليوم مؤكده انها
استهدفت المدنيين بشكل مباشر في حي الدوحه
بي ام درمان ومنطقه الكلاكله جنوب الخرطوم
وقالت في بيان لها انها تعمل على تقديم
الخدمات الاساسيه وفتح ممرات انسانيه في
هذه المرحله الصعبه التي تشهدها السودان
الى جانب انشغالها باجلاء البعثات
الدبلوماسيه ورعايد وللاجنبيه
اظهرت مقاطع فيديو حصريه لقناه العربيه
حجم الدمار والاضرار التي خلفها القصف على
منطقه الكلاكيلا القبه الواقعه جنوب
الخرطوم متابع
[تصفيق]
في بيت وقع الان
بار ده
[موسيقى]
السودان
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله العلي العظيم
اذا مشاهدينا اسبوع ثان من المواجهات
المسلحه في السودان لا صوت يعلو على صوت
الرصاص ولا مؤشره ينظر بحل قريب المواجهه
بين الجيش والدعم السريع بدات باطلاق نار
كثيف حول مباني المدينه الرياضيه في منطقه
سوبا جنوبيه العاصمه الخرطوم القتال انتقل
فيما بعد سريعا الى حي المطار المتاخم
لمقر القياده العامه للجيش حيث يوجد بيت
ضيافه الذي يقيم فيه طرف الحرب البرهان
وكبار القاده العسكريين وسط الخرطوم
وبينما تداولت وسائل الاعلام عن الدعم
السريع سيطرته على مطار مروي والقاعده
الجويه اضافه الى الاعلان عن احتجاز عدد
من الضباط كانوا في القاعده تم تداولوا
معلومات عن السيلاء قوات الدعم السريع على
القصر الجمهوري في قلب الخرطوم اضافه الى
اجزاء واسعه من مقر القياده العامه للجيش
نيران الحريق امتدت بعدها الى خارج
الخرطوم لتصل عددا من المدن مثل نيالا
والف اشر والجنينه في ولايه دارفور ومدينه
الاوبيض في ولايه شمال كردوفانى القتال
تركز ايضا على مقرات دعم السريع في شارع
عبيد ختم وفي مدينه بحري ومدرمان ليس
معروفا على وجه الدقه من يسيطر على ماذا
فكل طرف يزعم بصاص سيطرته على موقع
استراتيجي قبل ان يبادر الطرف الاخر سريعا
فيما بعد باعلان الشيء نفسه
[موسيقى]
وثقت مقاطع مصوره تصاعد اعمده الدخان في
محيط السفاره الكويتيه بالخرطوم اثرى
الاشتباكات الدائره نتابع
[موسيقى]
انا طلعت
بيقول لي طلعت منه 17 سنه
[موسيقى]
وبينما تستمر عمليات اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب من السودان مع استمرار المواجهات
قال لواء بحر ركن صالح بن بكر عمر قائد
الفرقه 101 مشاه في البحريه السودانيه
للعربيه قال ان هناك تسهيلات لاجراءات
دخول سفن اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب وحاولنا
نسهل كل الاجراءات المتعلقه
بالمواني بدخول السفن
ورباطه وايضا بوصول الرعايه هنا وتجميعهم
وضيافتهم وما الى ذلك من من اجراءات حقيقه
كانت عمليات الاجلاء يعني بطريقه سلسه جدا
سهل كل الاجراءات حتى الاجراءات الرسميه
للجوازات
والجمارك كانت في مكان استقبال هذه
الجاليات الان احنا بصدد عندنا الان بتحمل
ثلاثه سفن اللي هي سفن من المملكه من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وعندنا سفينه هنديه
وعندنا سفينه كوريه جنوبيه وفي انتظار عدد
اخر من السفن الحقيقه
هذا وكانت اعلنت الولايات المتحده انها
سترسل سفنا من اسطولها البحري لاجلاء
رعاياها في السودان وقالت جون كيربي
المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي في البيت
الابيض انه ليس هناك عمليات اجلاء كبيره
وان الوقت غير مناسب لاجراءها كما اضاف ان
عشرات الامريكيين يتحركون برا مع قوافل
الامم المتحده الى بورت سودانا
قصائد
سيدرا
نتابع هذه التطورات بالمزيد من التفاصيل
والمعلومات مع ضيفنا من الخرطوم السفير
عبد الرحمن خليل ناطق الرسمي باسم
الخارجيه السودانيه اهلا بك معنا مع
السفير الى هذه التغطيه المستمره للتطورات
وللازمه السودانيه اسمح لي ان ابدا معك
بعمليات الاجلاء جوا ما هي اخر التفاصيل
وما هي المطارات خاصه المؤمنه والمتاحه
لنقل الرعايه الدول المختلفه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم التحيه لقناه
العربيه والساده المشاهدين
السودان وانطلاقا من مسؤوليته
مسؤوليته اتجاه حمايه الرعايه
والدبلوماسين والاجانب
كل الاجهزه الحكوميه بما فيها وزاره
الخارجيه
والاجهزه العسكريه والشرطيه
والسلطات المطارات تقوم بتقديم التسهيلات
اللازمه
لتسهيل
الرعايه الجانب
في توفير المطارات وتوفير الممرات الامنه
والتسهيلات لكل الامور اللوجستيه التي
التي تستخدمها الدول الدول لترحيل رعاياها
سواء كان اذونات الطائرات او حمايه
القوافل التي تنقل
الرعايه والدبلوماسيين الاجانب
وتوفير كل التسهيلات الممكنه لهم في هذه
الحاله صحيح ولكن من يؤمن برا مثلا حدثتني
عن تامين هذه القوافل عن طريق البر وحضرتك
تعلم بانه من الخرطوم الى بورتسودان هناك
العديد من الساعات عشر ساعات تقريبا صحح
لي ان كان هنا خطا في هذه المعلومه عشر
ساعات هناك اشتباكات على امتداد هذا
الطريق من يؤمن وصول القوافل من الخرطوم
الى بورتسودان الجيش او هناك استعانه
بمنظمات اخرى
القوات المسلحه السودانيه هي التي توفر
الحمايه لكل الله لكل القوافل التي تتحرك
من من الخرطوم الى الى بورسود
طيب وبالنسبه للجو بالنسبه للمطارات قلت
حضرتك بان هناك مطارات نوفرهن وامنها
لتمكين الدول من
محاوله على الاقل هبوط الطائرات ومساعده
رعاياها هذه المطارات يمكن ان نسميها
بالطبع ممكن ان نسميها وكثير من الدول
اجلت رايها
عبر المطارات العسكريه
عبر مطار بورسودان
ما هي قلت لي بانه لا حرج في ان نسميها ما
هي هي هذه المطارات اعطينا لمحه على
تامينها كيف يتم
كل المطارات العسكريه التي
مطارات معمره تماما
طيب هذا بالنسبه للمطارات
الاخرى
تفاعلت معكم او
تواصلت معكم
بخصوص رعاياها بخصوص عمليه الاجلاء
كل الدول كل الدول
اتصلت وتواصلت معنا بخصوص ايجار اياها وهي
تختار الطريقه المناسبه سواء كان ترسل
طائرات تهبط في المطارات العسكريه ومن ثم
يتم تعميم نقل المواطنين والرعايه الى تلك
المطارات ام عن طريق
الحافلات التي تتحرك من الخرطوم الى
بورسودان وعدد كبير جدا من السفارات يعني
يعني نظمت عمليه ترحيل عن طريق البر من
الخرطوم الى بورسودان وتم تامين هذه
القوافل الى ان وصلت الى بورسودان ومن
هنالك
اما تستقل الطائرات اما تستقل السفن
الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه ومنها الى
الوجهات المعنيه انتم كوزاره خارجيه سيد
خليل هل لديكم احصائيات او اعداد دقيقه
ومحدده لاعداد الدبلوماسي ين والرعايه
عموما الذين غادروا السودان منذ بدايه
الاشتباكات
الاعداد متغيره يعني كل يوم
يتم ترحيل اما ان يكونوا في طريقهم الى
الترحيل
فيصعب
وضع رقم محدد في هذه اللحظه الى ان يتم
عمليه الترحيل ولكن يعني معظم معظم الدول
الاوروبيه
والدول العربيه
نستطيع ان نقول يعني اكمل
الدبلوماسيه ولكن هنالك بعض بعض الرعايه
الاجانب يعني لم يتم حتى من الدول الغربيه
الامريكيه لم يتم
ترحيلهم ربما ربما ربما يكون في الخطوه
الثانيه الدول الاسيويه الان كلها في
طريقها اما عن طريق البر واما وصلوا الى
بورسودان وفي بعض الدول ما زالت تجمع
رعاياها في مناطق محدده وتنفق عمليه
ترحيل هايله بورسود ما صعوبات التي
تعترضكم في عمليه ترحيل سواء برا او جوا
الصعوبات تتمثل في الخروقات التي تقوم بها
القوات المتمرده من حينز اخر
وتعترض الطريقه الطريقه القوافل احيانا
مثلا
الفريق القطري او
القافله القطريه يعني تعرضت تعرضت لبعض
الهجوم ولكن يعني استطاعت القوات
السودانيه ان ان تحميها وكذلك
القافله الفرنسيه هو متجهه الى احدى
المطارات العسكريه في الطريق تعرضوا الى
بعض
المناوشات من قوات
التمرد التي تسعى الى التقريب والتعرض
الدبلوماسيين وممتلكات الدبلوماسيين
ايضا من وتتخذ ايضا من المواطنين دروعا
بشريه
هذا هذا ما يقوله الجيش
السوداني ودعم السريع كذلك في المقابل
يتهم بنفس الاتهام هو التصريحات تاتي من
الجانبين ولكن سيد خليل في هذا الاطار
البعض يلاحظ بان اليومين الاخيرين كان
هناك زخم في عمليه اجلاء رعايه وهنا كانت
هناك قراءه بان الايام القادمه بعد عمليه
اجراء كل الرعايه ستكون ايام صعبه سيشتد
فيها القتال حضرتك بحسب خبرتك الدبلوماسيه
هل هذه القراءه دقيقه
لا لا احد يستطيع ان التوقع بما يحدث في
الايام القادمه ولكن لكن القوات المسلحه
السودانيه تؤدي دورها وفي قمع التمرد
واعاده الامور الى نصابها والانتهاء من
هذا الوضع الشاذ لقوات
الدعم السريع المتمرده سيد خليل هل حقيقي
بان هناك مسلك لمحاوله التفاوض مع الدعم
السريع فتحت بشكل او باخر فتحتها جهات في
الداخل او في الخارج تتواصلون او هناك
وساطه
يقوم بها احد الاطراف
هنالك جهات عده عرضت الوساطات لكن قبل
الانتهاء هذه المهمه يكون
ليس ليس هناك فرص للتفاوض ما قبل انتهاء
هذا الوضع الشاذ وردع التمرد
وقمع المحاوله الانقلابيه
بلا يمكن كان اكد بان هناك جهود امريكيه
سعوديه اماراتيه مصريه لطرح نوع من
الوساطه ماذا في تفاصيل هذا الموضوع سيد
خليل
كل الوساطات ليس ذلك فحصت وان عدد من
الدول الافريقيه والدول المجاوره كلها
طرحتها ولكن لكنها يعني تطلب في البدايه
وقف القتال
ومن بعد ومن بعد يمكن التحدث عنه او
التفاوض ولكن
هذا وضع شاص ولا وفي محاوله انقلابيه
وتمرد من جهه من جهه عسكريه لا بد من
القضاء عليها ومن ثم بعد ذلك كان يكون
التفاوض
من الجهه اللي قادره ان تؤثر او على الاقل
ان تطرح وساطه ومبادره فعليه تقبل من
جهتكم من جهه
الجيش السوداني
الوصفات كثيره
وجهات كثيره مؤهله لذلك
ودول صديقه ودول
دول دول مؤثره العالميه ولكن هذه هذه
المبادرات اذا لم تاتي في الوقت اذا لم
يكن في الوقت وقت المناسب او الوقت المتاح
قبل
بحسب قراءه حضرتك ما الوقت المناسب
الوقت المناسب هو القضاء على التمرد
لماذا اخفق وقف الاقتتال تماما لماذا هذه
هذه الهدنه الاخيره مثلا اخفقت في ان
تتوقف الاشتباكات ان يتوقف الاقتتال تماما
ليطرح فيما بعد شكل من اشكال المبادرات
بسبب بسبب الخروقات المستمره
لقوات الدعم السريعه المتبرده للهدنه
محاوله
تحسين مواقعها وكسب اعراض جديده وتحسين
والتموضع في اماكن استراتيجيه والتغلق
داخل داخل
المناطق السكنيه والمرافق العامه
لاتخاذها دروعا دروعا
تختبئ وراها من من من من قوات المسلحه
السودانيه
طيب اود شكرك جزيلا شكر كنت معنا من
الخرطومه سفير عبد الرحمن خليل الناطق
الرسمي باسم الخارجيه السودانيه شكرا
جزيلا لك وفي هذا الاطار مشاهدينا كذلك
نتحرك كل هذه التصريحات والمعلومات
وتطورات من الجهه المقابله كذلك ومعنا عبر
الهاتف فارس النور مستشار الفريق محمد
حمدان ديجلو اهلا بك معنا سيد فارس سيد
فارس ان كنت تستمع منذ قليل كان معنا
المتحدثه وناطق الرسمي باسم الخارجيه
السودانيه وبحسب تصريحاته هو يقول بانكم
تعطلون سير القوافل برا
لاجلاء الرعايه ما ردكم على هذا التصريح
ان هذا الامر غير صحيح
والخروقات التي تاتي دائما تاتي من الاخر
لاحظتي في كلامه هو يرفض كيف هو كانه
يتوهم انه يريد ان يقضي على التمرد كما
قال وبالتالي هو الذي يعني يشعر انه يريد
ان لا يريد هدنه بل يريد ان يقضي على
التمرد فبالتالي هو الطرف الذي يقترح وهو
الطرف الذي لا يلتزم بالهده نحن لمن نلتزم
بالهدنه اختي الكريمه نلتزم بها من دواعي
التزمنا بها من اجل التخفيف على ابناء
شعبنا في في الاول من اجل فرحه العيد ومن
اجل اجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب ولكن
على الارض نحن متقدمون نحن نحتل مواقع
استراتيجيه الان كل يوم نحن في تقدم عندما
نلتزم نلتزم بصدقا وهو عندما يلتزمون
يلتزمون مناوره وخداعا وكذبا واخرها قبل
ساعات كيف تقصف مدنيين بالطيارات يعني
يعني هذه في احياء سكنيه شعبيه حتى لو كان
اعدى اعداءك موجود في هذه لا يمكن ان يعني
جريمه دوليه جيده على العموم نحن متقدمون
نحن نفتقد الان نحن نفتقد للشريك الذي
نعمل معه الهدنه يعني
الشريك الاممي تتحدث سيد فارس من الشريك
سيد فارس قلت بانه هناك شريك تتواصلون معه
لمحاوله تثبيت هدنه هذا ما فهمت حضرتك
الذي
نتفاوض معه للهدله لذلك لابد ان يكون
الاتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار اولا
طيب وضحت هذه النقطه في مقابل كل هذا
حدثتني منذ قليل قلت بانكم تؤمنون كذلك
سير القوافل لاجلاء الرعايه ما القوافل ما
الدول التي ساهمتم مثلا في تامين خروجها
من السودان
التي تواصلت معنا وكانت في مناطق نقودا
انها الفرنسيه والايطاليه والنيجر وكل
الدول
المحتلين المراكز الحيويه في الخرطوم فكان
التزامنا الاول اصلا يوفر اطلاق النار
التزامه الثاني تامين المناطق التزامنا
الثالث انه نحمي القطاع الطرق والذين طرف
التالي من انه يصل تلك
ليهدد القوافل هذه تمت مع الجميع ولكن
الذي يهمنا
المستشفيات عشان يقدروا يتحركوا للتمويل
عشان يقدروا يعني يتواصلوا
سيد فارس هل صحيح بانكم حاولتم التشويش
على عمليه اجلاء بعض القوافل انطلاقا مش
بعض القوافل اتحدث عن
يعني استهدفتم بعض المطارات التي كانت
تستعد لاجلاء بعض الرعايه قيل بان الدعم
السريع حاول التشويش على بعض هذه العمليات
ما حقيقه هذا الموضوع
اذا كان المتكلم مجنون والمستمعه لا يمكن
ان يكون المتكلم مجنون والمستمع نحن في اي
معركه نريد ان نكتب المجتمع الدولي
خلينا
نتعرض لمجتمع الدولي شنو يعني الا اذا كنا
نريد ان ننتحر نحن نعتقد اننا مع المجتمع
الدولي مع كل دعات الديمقراطيه في العالم
نقود معركه ضد دعاه الديكتاتوريه هذه
معركه لا يمكن في في هذا الامر ان ان نعيق
حلفائنا
اثنين نحن التزمنا بالهدنه وهذا التزام
صادق التزام حقيقي لذلك هذا ما فعلناه
ولدينا صور
سوف سوف تخرج في وقتها المناسب لكل
الاحساس التي احنا ساعدناه يعني كل
الوحدات تساعدناه في الوقت المناسب لم
افهم سيد فارس لماذا الوقت المناسب لان
الحديث صار كثير واخذ حجم كبير فيما يخص
تهديدكم لبعض المطارات
ولكن هذا ليس يعني لا اعتقد ان هذه مشكله
الان الكبرى هي نحن مع المجتمع الدولي
في تمام
التي يدعو لها الجميع
هذا الذي نريده اثنين يا سيدتي
نحن معركه قبل القدر نحن كنا وافقنا على
ان نسلم السلطه للحكومه المدنيه
ان اعمل الحاجه دي مع الثلاثه يوم هل نحن
كنا تقارى وصحينه ولا ماذا حدث الحدث ابنه
هنالك طرف كان يظن انه يعتمد على خلافات
المدني المدنيه فليس محتاج لانه يعمل
مشكله لما المدنيين اتفقوا والموضوع مشى
هو اصبح معصورا لذلك اراد
ان الاوضاع سيد فارس ساعود معك لهذه
النقطه ولنقطه المبادرات تعلم حضرتك بان
هناك مبادرات وهناك محاوله للوصفات مختلفه
افريقيه اقليميه ولكن اسمح لي ان اعود
لتفصيل اخر كان ورد في بيانات كنا اطلعنا
عليها
مفادها بان الدعم السريع يستخدم المباني
السكنيه للاحتماء بها ويستخدم المدنيين
كضروع بشريه
يا سيدي
لا يمكن لل
دعم يقولوا لك مرارا وتكرارا نحن الان نحن
متقدمون في المعركه ونقبل المدن من اي
شعبنا نقبل الهدنه من اي شعبه ولكن الذي
يحدث ان هنا
لك يرتدي ملابس الدعم السريع ويريد ان
يشويها صورتنا لذلك هو
يعني يمشي للمناطق السكنيه ويضربها وكما
قلت لك هنالك غصب المدنيين بالطيارات هم
لو ارادوا ولكن نقطه ملفته سيد فارس صحيح
ولكن سيد فارس نقطه ملفته ما تتفضل
بالاشاره لها تقول حضرتك بان هناك بعض
المندسين الذين يرتدون ملابس تشبه ملابس
دعم السريع او هي نفسها تقريبا وهم من
يحتمون بالمدنيين يحاولون التشويش على
حضوركم في مختلف هذه المناطق حدثنا اكثر
عن هذه المعلومات يا سيدتي نحن منذ
هنالك هو الذي يعني يقوم
بهذه تمثيليه انه
يعتمد على التراتبيه في الاحصاء الاو
امر للجيش الجيش يع
تمد على
التراتبيه في الامر لذلك بفضل الاعتصام
الذين موجودين في
القياده الع
ليا نحصل الاوامر مج نون الاعتصام الان
نفس السيناريو يتكرر من هم في القياده
وارادوا ان يقودوا الناس الى المحرقه
والديكتاتوريه اعطوا الاوامر وغدروا الدعم
السريع ووضعوا شرفاء القوات المسلحه
وضعوهم امام المعركه وعملوا حرب نفسيه
كبيره جدا عشان الناس ما تقدر ترجع نقول
انه نحن كررنا كثير يا سيدتي نحن قبل
ثلاثه يوم نحن النقطه المهمه انه نحن ما
طارحين نفسنا بديل للقوات المسلحه نحن كنا
بنتفاوض معاهم انه نحن حدا مع بعض دايرين
نكون واحد يحمي الدستور
واحد يقدر يحمي البلد يحمل الحكومه
المدنيه ويحكم التحول الديمقراطي كيف بعد
ثلاثه يوم نبقى نحن الاعداء ونحن اللي
بنعمل
هذا
[موسيقى]
الامر يدبر هذه النقطه ولكن سيد فارس قلت
منذ قليل بان هناك ما وصفتهم بالشرفاء
داخل الجيش السوداني اعترفت بان هناك
شخصيات قادره ان تتفاعلوا تتواصلوا معها
هي شخصيه مقبوله لدى الدعم السريع فالسؤال
هنا هل تتواصلون مع بعض الاشخاص المعروفين
بانتسابهم للجيش
هنالك في القوات المسلحه شرفاء حتى انهم
لا يحتاجون للت
للاسف نحن لما النظام السابق ابسطنا من
الذراع المدني الحكومه ولم نضبط الزراعه
العسكري الموجود داخل الجيش هؤلاء هم
الذين سيطروا على الجيش ولكن هنالك شرفاء
داخل القوات المسلحه والان
يبقى
انضم للدعم السريع بعضهم فرا وخل
القياده اصلا لانهم رافضين لهذا الامر فيا
سيدتي
من الليل لانه نحن حتى
الجنود هذه دماء عزيزه وغاليه علينا جدا
مما اخواننا كنا نتمنى ان نبني معهم جيشا
قوميا واحد
لرغبه السودان ماذا تطلبون قلت نطلب
نطلب منهم ان يحكموا عقولهم
يستطيع هم ان يزيحوا هذه القله ويستطيع ان
يكونوا القياده التي تليق بالجيش السوداني
التي تريد ان تذهب بالبلاد الى التحول
الاقتصادي وتجد اهداف ثوره اسمح لي سيد
فارس ان اختم معك بموضوع الوساطه تعلم
حضرتك بان هناك مبادرات عديده من من بين
هذه المبادرات او هذه الوساطه الاقرب
الاكيد بانكم اطلعتم على تفاصيل بعض هذه
الوصفات او المبادرات او الكلام الذي
وصلكم من بعض الاطراف من الاقرب من الجهه
الاقرب للدعم السريع والقادره ان تطرح وسط
حقيقيه
الجهه الاغربيه
نحن لدينا
المجتمع الدولي مع المجتمع الاوروبي مع
المحيط الاغليمي كل هؤلاء
وهم كانوا يرعوا
الاتفاق الاول
ولكن افتكر الان الاشكال الكبير هو مدى
الشريك الذي سوف تدير معه التفاوض نحن
عشان السودان لازم الاول يكون في اطلاق
النار يا سيدي هذه ما هو الشرط الذي بعده
نستطيع ان ننتقل اعتقد اصدقاء السودان في
المجتمع الدولي هم يريدون خيرا للسودان
وهم سوف يدعون معنا الى ان نصل الى
الاهداف التي نحن يعني وضعها الشعب
السوداني
ونريد وقف اطلاق نار حقيقي مشكله كلام
بتاعها الليله انت تقول لي كلام بعد يعني
يعني البرهان اصبح انت
لا تدري تصريحاته يعني هل اذا سالتيني ما
رايك في تصريحات القران اقول لك قبل
السؤال ولا بعده هذا رجل متنوع هذه قياده
مراوغه هذا كذب نحن مستعدون اذا هنالك
شريك حقيقي نعمل معه وقت لاطلاق نار حقيقه
واضح حتى فكره حضرتك اود شكرك جزيلا شكر
على كل ما تفضلت به من توضيحات من الخرطوم
عبر الهاتف فارس النور مستشار الفريق محمد
حمدان شكرا لك
هذا مشاهدينا ووصل رعايه ودبلوماسيون
كوريون قادمون من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم الى قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه
في جده في اطار عمليه الاجلاء نتابع
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الى هذه الكلمه لجيك سوليفان
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي السمع
حتى يتسنى لنا حمايه ذلك المجمع في الايام
والاسابيع القادمه
ونعتزم ان نستمر في هذه العمليه ولا اعلم
بما تعنيه بالقول عن الخسائر التي تعرضت
له السفاره لكن كما تعلمون ان كافه
العمليات
الدبلوماسيه في السودان قد تم
توقفها
واجلائي كافه طواقم السفاره هذا الامر
يحدث بين فتره واخرى اذا نظرتم الى الامر
على مر السنوات تجدون ان هناك خروجا لبعض
الطواقم الدبلوماسيه من بعض سفارات هذه هي
طبيعه العمل
وخاصه في ظل انتشار 270 دبلوماسي في كافه
انحاء العالم اذا كانت الظروف غير مئاتيه
للاستمرار في العمليات الدبلوماسيه في
منطقه ما لكن هدف نا كما قلت هو ان نستمر
في العمليات في الخرطوم بمجرد قدرتنا على
القيام بذلك
كما تعلمون عندما تتعلق الامور بمسائل
التاشيرات الخاصه بالروس فهذه فهذا فهذه
المساله تخص بالجهل المعنيه بتلقي طلبات
التاشيره الخاصه بالدبلوماسيين الروس
في سياق الحديث عن خطه الطوارئ المتعلقه
بالسودان هل تنظرون في مساله نشر قوات حفظ
سلام لا توجد لدينا اي مرحله اي خطط لنشر
خطط لنشر قوه حفظ سلام في السودان ليس في
الفتره الحاليه لا نتوقع انها سوف تكون
ايضا في الفتره القريبه
هل لديكم اي خطط طارئه فضلا عن اجلاء
طواقم
الطواقم الدبلوماسيه من السفاره
هل لك ان تشرح لنا ما هي خطه الطوارئ تلك
لن اتكهن بالاشياء التي لم تحدث بعد لكن
عندما يتعلق الامر بقدرتنا على الاستجابه
واذا ما شعرنا بانه كان هذا امرا لازما من
اجل حمايه موظفينا واذا ما كان هناك اي
تهديد نتعرض لها في الولايات المتحده
تمتلك القدرات للرد على ذلك لكن من
منظورنا في الفتره الحاليه نعتقد بان
المسار الحالي الذي نشده الا وهو ان نسه
ان نسهل
عمل الاجلاء هو الطريق الامثل للمضي قدما
وطالما ان اهدافنا لم تتعرض لاي تهديد
هناك
هل ترون اعدادا متزايده من الامريكيين
الذين يصلون الى بورسودان وهذا ما يدفع
الى الحيطه والحذر لعدم توجه اي مواطنين
امريكيين الى اماكن خطا خطره هل هناك اي
خطط بالنسبه للسفر هناك وتحذيرات هناك
هناك مخاطر عند تحليق طائرات الهليكوبتر
في تلك المنطقه نحن لا نتحدث عن اي خيارات
امنه لكن من واجبنا نبلغ الامريكيين بان
هناك عمليات اقتتال تدور في تلك البلاد
وسواء مكان السفر عبر عبر الجو او عبر
البر كلها سوف تكون مصحوبه بالمخاطر اننا
نقوم بحسابه ذاك المخاطر بصوره دقيقه
ومن خلال عمليات حسابنا للمخاطر كنا نخبره
مواطنين بعدم السفر الى السودان لكننا
نقول في ذات الوقت بان بالنسبه لهؤلاء
الامريكيين المهتمين في الانضمام لبعض
القوافل فكنا نقدم المعلومات حول كيفيه
قيامهم بذلك ونحن نقدم الان بعض
الدرجات المتزايده من الرقابه حول توج
تحركهم امريكيين بين في اعداد تلك القوافل
وسوف نكون واضحين مع الامريكيين حول
المخاطر وحول الخيارات المتوفره لهم وسوف
نستمر في اتصال نسيق مع هؤلاء الامريكيين
عبر الهاتف وزاره الخارجيه تقوم بهذا
الامر بصوره يوميه في بعض الحالات
سوف نكون حاضرين لاي امريكي في السودان
يبحث عن دعم وتوجيهات من الولايات المتحده
هل لديكم اي تحديث حول مساله وقف اطلاق
النار واذا مكان للولايات المتحده اي دورا
لتلعبه بين الاطراف المتقاتله وكيف يمكن
للولايات المتحده ان تلعب دورا مهما في
هذا الامر البيت الابيض كان قد اجرى
محادثات متعدده وكذلك الامر بالنسبه
لوزاره الخارجيه ومع سفيرنا الموجود على
الارض من خلال اتصالات هاتفيه متعدده
كذلك بعد خروجه من البلاد لن اتكهن حول ما
قد يحدث لان الاموريه ومتغيره ولكن
نامل ان يتم التوصل الى وقف اطلاق النار
الذي كان قد تم طرحه خلال فتره عيد الاضحى
لكنه لم يصمد
يبدو بان ان الاطراف المتحاربه خرق تلك
الخدمه تلك الحد وسوف نستمر بالعمل مع
شركائنا لدفع الطرفين المتقاتلين من اجل
تخفيض اعمال العنف وتوصل الى وقف اطلاق
اطلاق نار دائم لا استطيع ان اعطيكم
تنبؤات حول متى سوف يتم الوصول الى ذلك
لكننا نرى ان هناك امكانيه بمجرد
ممارسه وتطبيقي كافه الادوات المتوفره
لدينا لتحقيق هذا الغرب
يتعلق بكوريا الجنوبيه وحزمه المساعدات
والتمارين العسكريه
الرئيسان الامريكي ورئيسي كوريا الجنوبيه
كان قد تطرق الى مساله الردع المشترك
وخاصه من المخاطر
النابعه من الصين وانا سوف
القدر كان هذا مؤتمر صحفي لجيك سوني
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي وكانت هناك
مجموعه كبيره من الاسئله الخاصه بتطورات
في السودان وبالازمه السودانيه وكان اجاب
ووضح بعض المواقف الامريكيه تحدث مثلا عن
انو الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ليست لها
النيه او الخطه على الاقل في الوقت الحالي
لنشر قوات حفظ السلافه داخل السوداني ولكن
في المقابل اكد جيكسوليفان ان الولايات
المتحده لديها خطه لحمايه سف قال كذلك بان
تامين المدنيين في داخل السوداني هو
مسؤوليه طرفي النزاع اي الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع واكد كذلك بان الرئيس بايدن
طلب انتشارا عسكريا تحسبا لاي طرق بالازمه
السودانيه كذلك قال بان هناك
محادثات وهناك تواصل مع كل الاطراف
لمحاوله طرح صيغه
لفهم ما يحدث وكذلك حتى طرح صيغه وساطه
تخص هذه الاسماء على كل سنعود لهذه
التصريحات لمستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
جيكس ولكن في نشرات قادمه لمتابع كذلك
تطورات المواقف
الدوليه نتابع دائما مع نفس المواضيع ذات
اصيله من بين المواقف موقف المملكه
العربيه السعوديه حيث بحث وزير الخارجيه
السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان مع نظيره
الياباني يوشيماسا هياتشي جهود وقف
التصعيد العسكري في السودان وذكرت وكاله
الانباء السعوديه ان طرفين تطرق الى مساله
انهاء العنف وتوفير الحمايه اللازمه
للمدنيين وتهدئات التوترات المتصاعده في
عدد من المواقع الحيويه داخل البلاد
كما بحث وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان مع نظيره الاماراتي يا شيخ
عبد الله بن زايد جهود وقفي اطلاق النار
في السودان وزير الخارجيه الاماراتي ثمنا
دور المملكه في عمليه اجلاء رعايه
الامارات والعديد من دول العالم من
السودان الى السعوديه مشيدا بالجهود
البارزه التي تقوم بها السعوديه بتنفيذ
عمليه الاجلاب بالتعاون مع مختلف الدول
مشاهدينا قبل المتابعه نشير الى هذه
العواجل بيان لطيران فلاي دبي نذكر ونجمل
ما كنا نتابعه اسفل الشاشه وهذه العواجه
لا زالت مستمره نتابعها دائما اسفل الشاشه
اذا بيان لطيران فلايد دبي يؤكد بان
الرحله القادمه من نيبال تعرضت للاصطدام
بطائره اثناء الاقلاع نذكر بانه هذا او
بطائر عفوا بطائر نذكر بانه كانت هناك
مشاهد لاشتعال النار على مستوى هذه
الطائره فهذا البيان يوضح ما الذي حدث
بياني طيران فرايد يقول بان هذه الرحله
القادمه من نيبال تعرضت طائره الاصطدام من
بطائر اثناء الاقلاع كذلك هذا البياني
يؤكد بانه تم اتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه
للتاكد من سلامه الطائره القادمه من نابال
وبان هذه الطائره تتجه في مسارها الطبيعي
نحو مطار دبي
في حدود 12 اي منتصف الليل والربع بتوقيت
الامارات على كل هذا البيان الخاص بطيران
فلاي دبي نذكر من جديد بهذه الاخبار التي
وردت في بيان لطيران فلاي دبي الذي اكد
بان هذه الرحله القادمه من نيبال تعرضت او
هذه الطائره بالاحرى تعرضت الاصطدام بطائر
اثناء الاقلاع وبان تم اتخاذ الاجراءات
اللازمه للتاكد من سلامه الطائره القادمه
من نيبال وبان هذه الطائره تتجه كما يؤكد
هذا البيان تتجه الى مسارها الطبيعي نحو
مطار دبي وستصل في حدود منتصف الليل سنقف
على المزيد من التطورات تبقى العين على
هذا البيان على هذه
العواجل وينضم لنا مراسل العربيه عبد الله
المطوع عبد الله اهلا بك معنا نحن بصدد
قراءه هذه العواجل تضعنا في اطار التطورات
الواضح بحسب هذا البيان بان الطائره
اصطدمت بطائر عند القلوع هذا عاده او عند
الاقلاع عفوا هذا عاده يحدث حدثت فيما قبل
مع
يعني طائرات اخرى ولكن ماذا في تفاصيل
وصول الطائره
عبد الله تسمعني
نحاول ان نتواصل مع زميل عبد الله المطوع
يبدو بانه الاتصال فصل ساعيد واذكر بمختلف
العواجل التي وردتنا منذ قليل نحن بصدد
الاطلاع على بيان لطيران فلاي دبي الذي
يؤكد بان الرحله القادمه من نيبال تعرضت
للاصطدام
بطائره اثناء الاقلاع هذه صور طائر اثناء
الاقلاع هذه الصور مباشره
لمسار هذه الطائره باتجاه مطار دبي اذا
بيان لطيران فلاي دبي يؤكد بان الرحله
القادمه من نيبال تعرضت لاصطدام بطائر
اثناء الاقلاع وبان كل الاجراءات تم
اتخاذها للتاكد من سلامه الطائره القادمه
من نابال وهذه الطائره كما نتابع الان
مسارها باتجاه مطار دبي بحسب البيان هي
ستصل في حدود منتصف الليل عبد الله المطوع
صار جاهز معنا عبد الله اهلا بك معنا ضع
نا في اطار اخر التفاصيل نحن بصدد التذكير
بمجاء في بيان لطيران فلاي دبي هذه
الطائره قد تصل في حدود منتصف الليل اليوم
الى مطار دبي صحيح
[موسيقى]
يعني لو كان هناك اي اصاب يعني ضرر على
رحله الطائره ربما كان الطيار لجا الى
الهبوط الاضطراري في احدى المطارات او
العوده الى مطار النيبال نؤكد حسب ما كان
واضح من بيان المتحدث الرسمي بطيران فلاي
دبي بان الطائره المتوجهه الى مطار دبي
الدولي يعني
تتخذ مسارها الطبيعي
واصولها الى مطار دبي في الوقت المحدد
وسلامه الركاب ربما هي الاهم وسلامه
الطائره هي ربما العنوان الاهم في هذه
الرحله صحيح وما تقوله نحن نتباهه الان
انت تقول بان هذه الطائره تتخذ مسارها
الطبيعي وستصل في توقيتها المبرمج لوصولها
لمطار دبي ونحن في الواقع عبد الله نتابع
هذه الصور هي صوره مباشره لهذه الطائره
وهي في طريق ها الى مطار دبي وتسلك هذا
الطريق باتجاه مطار دبي ستصل في حدود
منتصف الليله وربع شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الله
المطوع مراسل العربيه على كل ما تفضلت به
من تفاصيل
مشاهدينا
سنعود لهذه التطورات ولكن بالعوده كذلك
الى الملف الرئيس في هذه الساعه والخاص
بهذه التغطيه تطورات في داخل السوداني
للوقوف على اكثر تفاصيل ينضم لنا عبر
سكايب من نيروبي كارل المتحدث باسم المجلس
النرويجي للاجئين في شرق افريقيا
سيد كارل اهلا بك معنا سيد كارل هناك حديث
عن
نزوح الالاف ان لم نكن نتحدث عن عشرات
الالاف لانه عمليه التعداد صعبه بوجود
حالات غير قادره او احياء غير قادره
المنظمات على الوصول لها حضرتك كيف تتابع
هذا الموضوع وهل تقيمون كذلك حركه النزوح
او اللجوء كذلك خارج الحدود
فمن الصعب كليا ان نصل الى الصوره الكامله
لما يجري في السودان في الفتره الحاليه
فالناس يفرون من بيوتهم عبر الحدود الى ما
يعتقدون انها اماكن امنه وليست بالضروره
ان تكون فعلا امنه
وهم يغيرون مواقعهم يوما تلوى الاخر وفقا
للاوضاع الامنيه لذا من الصعب ان
نحتفظ او ان نتابع عدد الارقام لكن هناك
الالاف الذين يفرون من الخرطوم من العاصمه
وهو من الفاشر ودارفور
وبعض الاماكن الساخنه الاخرى التي يهرب
فيها المدنيون بعد تعرضهم لنيران الاطراف
المتقاتله وكان لابد لهم من الفرق من
الصعب ان نعطيكم اي ارقام في الفتره
الحاليه فنحن انفسنا
كمنظمه انسانيه نعاني في هذه المرحله لفهم
النطاق الكامل
للوضع هناك لكن ما استطيع ان اخبرك اياه
هو ان زملائي الذين استثنى لهم الخروج في
بعض المناطق الامنه قد تدبروا امرهم
للتحدث الى بعض الفارين والنازحين الذين
ذكروا لهم الصعوبات والرحله
المضنيه في اثناء خروجهم من الخرطوم
الى واد مدامي التي
تقع في الجنوب شرقي العاصمه فهناك وعلى
مسافه فاضطر الناس الى الى المشي الى 160
كيلو مترا على مدى عده ايام لبلوغ بعض
النقاط في ظروف صعبه ونحن نساعدهم في
تامين الماوى والغذاء والمياه وبعض
الاساسيات الضروريه الاخرى سيد كارلوس
بالبقاء معي حضرتك تعلم باننا نناقش هذا
التطورات ولكن كذلك نحن نتابع اخر
التفاصيل التي تاتينا من الداخل السوداني
وفي اخر هذه التطورات في الواقع الجيش
السوداني يقول ان قوات الدعم السريع
استهدفت سياره مساعد الملحق العسكري
المصري باحد شوارع الخرطوم عن الجيش
السوداني بحسب طبعا الجيش السوداني هو
يقول بان قوات الدعم السريع استهدفت سياره
مساعد الملحق العسكري المصري باحد شوارع
الخرطوم الاكيد بان هذا التطور سيبقى
للمتابعه ولكن كذلك
للنقاش في نشرتنا القادمه ومشاهدينا
نعزي الشعب المصري هكذا يقول الشعب
السوداني يقول بانه يعزي الشعب المصري
ويدين استهداف قوات الدعم للبعثات
الدبلوماسيه
والمدنيين دائما بحسب تصريحات الجيش
السوداني الذي يؤكد بانه يقدم التعازي
للشعب المصري ويقول بانه يدين استهداف
قوات الدعم للبعثات الدبلوماسيه
والمدنيين
سنعود الى هذا التطور ولكن اعود لك من
جديد سيد كارل حضرتك من خلال هذه العواجل
اكيد بانك قرات بان هناك مخاوف امنيه
جدا
حساسه وجديه فيما يخص التحرك في الداخله
السوداني او كذلك فيما يخص عمليه الاجلاء
وفي هذا الاطار حدثتنا عن صعوبات قلت بان
البعض يمشي لاكثر من 160 كيلومتر للوصول
الى مناطق امنه
للوصول الى الحدود ولكن ما هي الصعوبات
الامنيه التي حدثوك عنها كذلك
من المدنيين السودانيين كان كانوا قد
اجبروا على الفرار من بيوتهم بقدر الامكان
في ظروف صعبه وخطره للغايه
وكانوا ينتظرون لعمليات الاغتسال لتهدا
قليلا لاتمام خروجهم في ظل تلك الاوضاع
الصعبه
التي عاشها زملائي
وفي ظل هذه الظروف التي تتجلى لحظه تلو
الاخرى وتبدو ويبدو بانها تسير بالاتجاه
السيء فالناس قد نفذ منهم
الغذاء ومياه الشرب ومياه الغسيل والاسعار
قد تضاعفت عده مرات
يوما تلو الاخر في المحل التجاريه ولا
يوجد اي وقود بالمقاطعه اعلم بان هناك
ترجمه التطورات تفرض نفسها والعوازل كذلك
تفرض نفسها سيد كارل اسمح لي فقط ساعود لك
بعض لحظات لاننا بصدد متابعه هذا البيان
للجيش السوداني الذي اكد بعد تقديمه
العزاء لشعب المصري وادانته استهداف قوات
الدعم للبعثات الدبلوماسيه والمدنيين الان
الجيش السوداني يتحدث عن مقتل مساعد
الملحق العسكري المصري بالخرطوم باستهداف
سيارته على الطريق العام اذا الجيش
السوداني يؤكد مقتل مساعد الملحق العسكري
المصري بالخرطوم باستهداف سيارته على
الطريق العام وهذا بيان خاص بالجيش
السوداني كان اكد فيه بدايه بان قوات
الدعم السريع استهدفت سياره مساعد الملحق
العسكري المصري باحد شوارع الخرطوم والان
نتحدث عن تاكيد من الجيش السوداني دائما
نشير الى ان هذه التصريحات منسوبه للجيش
السوداني الذي يؤكد فيها مقتله مساعد
الملحق العسكري المصري بالخرطوم باستهداف
سيارته على الطريق العام
سنتابع كل هذا ولكن ساكتفي معك بهذا القدر
سيد كارشكندره المتحدث باسم المجلس
النرويجي لللاجئين في شرق افريقيا شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نتابع بهذا اللقاء هذا اللقاء
بين والي البحر الاحمر والبعثات
الدبلوماسيه نذهب لهذه المشاهد ونعود
هذه هي المره الاولى التي استطيع ان ابتسم
فيها خلال الساعات الاربعه وعشرين الماضيه
كانت صعبه للغايه
وانا سعيد
ومسرور لاننا هنا جميعا نشعر بالامان بعد
ان خرجنا من الخرطوم برحله طويله لكننا
انجزنا هذا الامر سويه
تعرضنا لبعض عمليات القصف اثناء رحلتنا
لكن لكن انه الامر رائع باننا وصلنا الى
بر الامان
[موسيقى]
وخاصه في ظل ظروفي القصر انني ممتن لكم
جميعا لانكم استطعتم
ان تعملوا في ظل تلك الظروف الصعبه
ووصلتم الى هنا امنين
وانني ممتن الى بعض الاشخاص بعينهم الذين
تدخلوا
عندما كانت الحاجه تقضي بذلك
وتقدموا العون الضروري لنا جميعا
ودعوني اقول بعض الكلمات لافراد محددين
دون تسميتهم
شكرا جزيلا لجون من
لجنه الالقاد الدوليه
ومن الصليب الاحمر فقد ساعدنا على الخروج
من الخرطوم
وقد قامت بعمل رائع
وقام بعمل رائع الم
فلنشكر
كافه هؤلاء الذين سهلوا لنا مساله الوصول
الى هذا المكان الامن نشكره كافه السائقين
الذين
سهلوا تلك المهمه وذللوا كافه الصعاب
ودون جهودهم لم كنا لنصل الى هنا
ورغم كافه الصعوبات والقياده لمسافه تزيد
عن 900 كيلومتر استطاعوا ان ينجزوا تلك
المهمه
والشكر موصول الى هؤلاء الذين تدخلوا
عندما دعت الحاجه لذلك
واشكر على وجه التحديد شخصين
محددين
على تنظيمهما لكافه الاشياء التي كنا
نحتاجها اثناء رحلتنا
وعلى تسهيل
عمليه النقل
قد
ر هذا المبعو
ثه تحدث وشكر خاصه من مكانه من الخروج من
الخرطوم قال بانه نحن صرنا لمسافه 900 كلم
وتمكنا من الوصول الى منطقه اسمها
بالمنطقه الامنه سنعود الى هذه الكلمه
ولكن هذه التغطيه مستمره بكل ما تشمله من
تفاصيل بعد قليل ليال الاختيار تلقاكم
لمتابعه هذه التطورات ابقوا معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات